meet Sarah Sarah is a sales professional
and a tungle me user when she wants to
meet with clients she turns to tungl me
because with tungl me there are no
costly double bookings no time zone
mishaps and no more email ping pong
trying to find a time that works for
everyone here's how it
works John is Sarah's client Sarah
emails him the details of an upcoming
project he wants to book a call to
discuss
so he clicks the tungl me link in
Sarah's email signature he arrives at
her tungl me page to see the times when
she is free he clicks to schedule the
meeting adds details selects a few
available times and
sends Sarah receives the email
invitation she sees the times John has
proposed overlaid on her own
calendar she picks a time that works and
clicks book meeting the meeting is
automatically added to Sarah's calendar
and John receives an email confirmation
to add to his
calendar it's as simple as
that Sarah's tungl me page only displays
times that she wants shown as available
she has set her availability for
mornings and afternoons every Monday to
Thursday she has also sink tungl me with
her calendar so that as new events are
added to her calendar tungl me will
automatically update her availability
and she won't be double booked Sarah has
also chosen to add a photo contact info
and a link to her personal blog on her
tungl me page she can share the link to
her page anywhere she connects she adds
it to her email signature Skypes it to
clients tweets it to followers posts it
on her LinkedIn profile and even prints
it on her business cards soon everyone
is tongling making scheduling even
easier easier for Sarah she can search
for colleagues in the tungl me directory
and add them to her contact list she can
schedule group meetings by selecting
from her contacts or adding names to a
tungl me URL to see everyone's availabil
overlaid she can invite non- tanglers to
meetings with just an email address and
they don't have to sign up to reply she
can even schedule meetings from her
iPhone or blackberry and respond to
meeting invitations from any smartphone
and that's how tungle me makes
scheduling meetings quick and easy for
Sarah so are you ready to tungle